hallo mein name ist luca der liebe
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
weiteren episode mit luc beaufort für
das heutige video habe ich mir natürlich
wieder kreativ wie ich bin eine
kleinigkeit überlegt denn die personen
die ich gleich treffen werde müssen
erraten was ich denen versuche
pantomimisch darzustellen
[Musik]
da kannst du dich auch lou cannon egal
alter krass ich kenne ich auch ja alle
krank du heißt jara unterstrich
ich habe mir für das video heute eine
kleinigkeit überlegt und zwar ein
pantomime spielt also ich werde dir
jetzt etwas darstellen und du musst
erraten was ich dir versuche
pantomimisch darzustellen
let's go hinfallen ein dicker
ausrutschen dass man kurz überlegen
das ist kein normaler teil
[Musik]
glatt als richtig glatt als perfekt ein
drittel möchte ja heute morgen also ich
habe mir für das video wohl gerade drin
seit etwas überlegt und zwar ein
pantomime spielen klappt ja also ich
muss einen begriff pantomimisch
darstellen denn hier warten müsst
[Musik]
wein trotzen
ja was ist ein anderer begriff gefunden
jungen mann bisher hat niemand so
richtig meine wörter raten die ich
vorbereitet habe
[Musik]
hey hey hallo also was hass auf deine
hand gemacht
das ist erhält und die gab es schon
verloren hat kann hier was was
was gab es zu kate meine chicken nuggets
verbrennen machen abschuss hallo mein
gott ich wurde gerade einfach
weggedrückt jetzt bin ich hier bei euch
[Musik]
ok
waren jetzt auch schon bei ford
so hey ich nehme gerade ein video auf
und habe ein kleines spiels mit euch vor
und zwar möchte ich meine pantomime
skills testen und euch etwas
pantomimisch darstellen was ihr erraten
müsste jetzt wirklich noch mehr leds mit
hintergründen
ja also ich hab da hinten ganz
[Musik]
ich mag diese ich hätte auch verlieren
so eine aber nur coole leute dürfen
sondern sonnenbrille besitzt und ich
glaube dann müssten leider nicht zu
diesem elitären kreis das ist ja du dich
ja ok hast du gesagt zuerst ladies first
data ich habe heute ein kleines
spielchen mit dir vor sex will so und
zwar möchte ich dir pantomimisch etwas
darstellen was du erraten musste ja
[Musik]
ring sitzen karussell
komisch sein
den sitzen verkehrskontrolle der verkehr
gerade jetzt wo du eine stunde später
[Musik]
fast zwei stunden später 5 stunden
später
[Musik]
poledance aidoo ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall noch ganz viel spaß hier
ich gehe mal weiter hast du eventuell
ein begriff für mich den ich als
nächstes pantomimisch darstellen kann ok
ich mein leben stimmt ist gut weil ich
als nächstes danke dir
[Musik]
hallo
ach du scheiße ich bin ja nicht mehr
luca versucht man fallen
nein beweist das
was konflikts er hat kein ticket okay
aber ich habe eine frage an euch habt
ihr bock auf'n pantomimisch spiel
ja ich mache jetzt was pantomimisch und
ihr müsst ihr raten was ich mache okay
und wenn jetzt richtig erwartet sage ich
euch ob ich gewinne oder nicht okay seid
ihr bereit
los geht's
[Musik]
werden die mainstage max de france das
gesicht vor dem körper sondern irgendwo
[Musik]
ein wenn dir das video hier seht schickt
eure krise hatte ich hoffe euch nie groß
[Musik]